venir manger c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui m'a passée depuis que j'ai
quatre cinq ans donc
je me suis accroché j'ai fait un stage
de troisième avec elle arrive dans une
boulangerie à côté du collège et au
final ça m'a plu je dis ouais allez
c'est parti
[Musique]
donc on a tous les deux 20 ans on s'est
connus au collège en 6e et puis on a
vraiment commencé à se côtoyer quand on
est sorti de troisième pour commencer
notre apprentissage dans le milieu de la
boulangerie pâtisserie
[Musique]
une bonne grosse partie soit faite pour
7h à l'ouverture du magasin
de traditions
au revoir pendant ce temps-là
à Jupille dans la Sarthe à Larry et
Thomas ont repris la boulangerie de leur
village dans laquelle ils ont d'abord
été apprentis pendant deux ans bonne
journée
mon ancien patron il m'a dit viens elle
arrive faut que je te parle la
boulangerie va être rachetée tout ça et
tout et je fais bah justement ça tombe
bien je vous en parler parce que je
voudrais je voudrais la racheter
également du coup avec Thomas on s'est
associé pour essayer de passer plus
facilement auprès des banques mais bon
malgré ça les banquettes elles ont pas
trop envie de suivre malheureusement par
le fait de notre âge et que du coup on
n'est pas forcément d'expérience dans la
dans le domaine de la gestion sauf que
bah non on peut pas se faire
d'expérience si on ne met pas l'occasion
de prouver notre valeur
ah du coup on a trouvé le système de la
location la location-gérance en gros
c'est à dire que le patron qui était là
avant nous donc ceux qui nous ont fait
en deux et ben en fait il reste
propriétaire du fond du commerce et en
fait une douleur fond de commerce pour
travailler dessus mais par contre il
travaille c'est vraiment comme si
c'était pas possible c'est une autre
société
de jeunes engagés motivés de 20 ans ce
qui est quand même formidable enfin
c'est une super nouvelle pour pour le
village donc maintenant il s'agit de les
aider et on a un an pour trouver des
financements donc quand ils ont besoin
on est à 15 km du petites villes c'est
loin tout en étant à côté pour les
habitants donc avoir ce commerce de
proximité c'est primordial ça fait aussi
venir des gens des villages alentours
donc pour ne pas avoir des cités dortoir
pour ne pas avoir des villages qui se
meurent on a besoin de de maintenir ses
commerces
il a 20 ans en âge mais en ajoutant il
est à peine 4 ans donc c'est compliqué
je suis en train de apprendre les
couleurs et les chiffres et demain on
verra l'alphabet
il y a le mercredi ou il y a l'un des
deux qui fait vraiment rien et autrement
il y a le samedi et dimanche ou c'est
l'après-midi donc là aussi le samedi
plus le dimanche après-midi ça fait un
jour de rencontre mais bon en général
même les jours de reposent quand même au
niveau des papiers des déplacements pour
voir quoi que ce soit c'est quoi les
projets pour la suite
moi je veux dire ça marche
après s'il y a des boulangers des
boulangers aux alentours qui sont entre
guillemets avant moi je sais que
personnellement ça sera en racheter
quelques unes et puis bah par la suite
moi mon plus grand projet à l'avenir ce
serait d'ouvrir ma boulangerie au Japon
j'aimerais bien aller vivre en bord de
mer avec sa copine et ouvrir une
boulangerie un peu plus grande j'aurais
pas besoin d'être là 24 heures sur 24 je
pourrais me prendre une journée sans
devoir fermer la boutique on est là
pendant un ange justement pour prouver
quand on est capable de deux gérer une
entreprise que on puisse suivre les
banques par la suite et
après on se balançait tout est possible
après
[Musique]